Der erste Hörer und Hörerinnen. Die Sendung musste abgebrochen werden, weil unser Inspezent leider verrückt geworden ist. Sie hören jetzt Musik auf Industrie-Schallplatten.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, die Ausgabe Nr. 18. Und heute läuft es mal ein bisschen anders als in den letzten Ausgaben, denn ich habe diesmal keinen Gast dabei, sondern mach das hier alleine und hab stattdessen ein paar voraufgezeichnete Interviews am Start, die ich hier gleich einspielen werde. Das Ganze ist von auf einer Veranstaltung aufgenommen worden von Dropping Knowledge, das ist eine Initiative, die sich hier letzte Woche in Berlin präsentiert hat. Es ist noch etwas schwierig, das zu bewerten, was da nun genau ist und wie viel Bedeutung das Ganze erlangen wird. Ich fand es aus zwei Aspekten erwähnenswert. Einerseits ist das so eine Gutmenschen-Initiative. Leute wollen mal was bewegen und haben den Eindruck, dass zu wenig bewegt wird. Da ist ja nichts gegen einzuwenden. Und haben es geschafft, die Unterstützung zu bekommen von der Allianz. Die gibt da Geld. Wie viel, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall wird da genug Geld bewegt, um Filme zu machen und für den Sommer wird so eine Aktion vorbereitet, wo 112 Leute aus aller Welt eingeladen werden, um Fragen zu beantworten. Diese Fragen werden auf der Webseite gesammelt. Und welchen Tiefgang das Ganze letztlich haben wird, das wird sich zeigen. Die beiden Aspekte, die ich jetzt interessant fand, dass ich das jetzt hier in den Podcasts hebe, sind einerseits die technische Realisierung des Ganzen, denn die Aufzeichnung, das wird jetzt gleich im Interview auch nochmal ganz deutlich erklärt werden. Also es gibt 112 Leute, die werden dann so in einem öffentlichen Raum in Berlin an so einem großen Tisch sitzen und Fragen beantworten. Und diese Beantwortungsszenerie, die wird halt komplett aufgezeichnet. Also jeder wird einzeln aufgezeichnet. Und da entsteht eine ganze Menge Material. Und das wird dann transkribiert und wird ausgewertet. Und zu dieser technischen Auswertung, aber auch zum Projekt im Allgemeinen, habe ich einen der Beteiligten, Hans Usko-Reit, der selber Wissenschaftler ist am Deutschen Forschungszentrum für Künstliche Intelligenz in Saarbrücken. Den habe ich dazu befragt. Das ist das erste Interview. Dann kommt noch ein zweites Interview hinterher mit dem Ralf Schmerwerk, der selber ein Filmregisseur ist. Da sage ich aber dann gleich nochmal was dazu. Ich blende jetzt erstmal über in das Interview, was ich mit Hans Usko-Reit geführt habe. Und danach hören wir uns wieder an. Wir sind jetzt hier bei der Veranstaltung von Dropping Knowledge, eine Initiative, die vor ein paar Tagen bekannt geworden ist, dadurch, dass sie an die Presse gegangen ist, die sich mit einem speziellen Projekt hier vorstellt. Mit mir ist Prof. Dr. Hans Usko-Reit, habe ich das richtig ausgesprochen, den ich mal ein paar Fragen zu dem Projekt stellen möchte. Worum geht es bei Dropping Knowledge und wann hat das angefangen?
Es geht bei dem Projekt darum, durch eine einzigartige Kombination ganz verschiedener Komponenten, einen Prozess des Dialogs in Gang zu setzen, eines Dialogs über soziale Fragen, über soziale Änderung, über sozialen Wandel, den es bis jetzt in der Form noch nicht gegeben hat. Diese Komponenten sind insbesondere eine Frage-Kampagne. Wir sammeln im Moment tausende, zehntausende von Fragen. Zu drängenden Problemen der Zeit aus diesen Fragen werden dann 100 Fragen ausgesucht, die sozusagen die Anfangsfragen für den Dialog bilden sollen. Wir werden dann 112, und keiner sollte fragen, warum das 112 sind, die Zahl ist einfach so entstanden, 112 Persönlichkeiten, Denker, Künstler, Philosophen, soziale Aktivisten aus aller Welt zusammenholen, die diese 112 Fragen beantworten. Und dann kommen da 11.200 Antworten heraus und das sollte eine gute Startmenge sein, Startguthaben, mit dem man so einen globalen Dialog vom Zaun brechen kann. Das wird natürlich nicht überraschend auf dem Internet passieren.
Wann ist die Initiative gestartet worden und wer ist wir in dem Zusammenhang?
Also die Initiative wurde gestartet. Die ursprüngliche Idee kam von den drei Gründern, heute Neudeutsch Founder genannt. Das sind Ralf Schmerberg, ein Filmregisseur aus Berlin, Jackie Wallace aus New York und jetzt Big Sur in Kalifornien und Cindy Gantz, eine Künstlerin und Filmemacherin aus den USA, aus Seattle. Ich bin im Herbst dazu gekommen, weil die drei, die mehr aus der Kunstszene kommen, jetzt nach Möglichkeiten gesucht haben, das Ganze auch später aufs Internet zu bringen und dort so zu organisieren, dass wirklich die ganze Welt sich am Dialog beteiligen kann.
Du hast ja eigentlich zu einem anderen Institut, dem DFKI, kannst du vielleicht dazu noch mal was zu sagen?
Ja, eigentlich komme ich aus einer ganz anderen Welt. Wir arbeiten hier jetzt mit Leuten aus der Umweltbewegung, aus der Filmszene, aus der Kunstszene zusammen. Ich selber komme aber aus der Wissenschaft, aus der Forschung. Wir machen etwas, was sich mit dem altmodischen Namen künstliche Intelligenz nennt. Wir würden das aber eher als kognitive Technologien bezeichnen. Wir bilden einerseits, wir programmieren oder modellieren auf dem Computer, bilden Abfähigkeiten, die sonst nur der Mensch hat. Aber konzentrieren uns eigentlich auf Anwendungen, die den Menschen helfen, und nicht den Menschen kopieren sollen.
Und welche Rolle soll jetzt diese Software und diese Techniken, die er da entwickelt, welche Rolle soll das in diesem Projekt spielen?
Ja, nachdem wir diese 11.000 Filme, 11.200 Antworten haben, die auch gefilmt sind, und die Übersetzung und die Texte, soll ja der globale Dialog wirklich losgetreten werden. Das kann heute nur auf dem Internet passieren. Die Technologie kann man sich einfach so vorstellen. Man nimmt erstmal was ganz Triviales, so etwas wie eine Forum-Software. Jeder kann dort selbst auf solche Fragen, auf die gestellten Fragen antworten, eigene Fragen einspeisen, Kommentare einspeisen, Links setzen, Hyperlinks auf andere Informationen, die vielleicht bestimmte Ansichten bestätigt oder widerlegt, oder auf künstlerische Werke zu Themen verweist. Dann hoffen wir, dass neue Fragen entstehen und neue Antworten. Aber leider ist es mit der einfachen Forum-Software nicht getan, sonst würde das Ganze viel zu unübersichtlich werden. Ist nicht online, aber wir haben die Software für das Archiv, in dem man durchsuchen kann, in dem man die 11.200 Fragen durchsuchen kann, die haben wir fertig. Man kann dort nicht einfach nur mit Wörtern, mit Suchwörtern wie bei Google suchen, sondern auch mit Themen oder sogar mit Fragen, die auf Englisch gestellt werden können, später vielleicht auch auf anderen Sprachen. Aber der zweite Teil des Ganzen, der das Ganze übersichtlich machen soll, der dann auch eine Visualisierung hat für die Zusammenhänge zwischen all den Themen und auch ein Rating-Bewertungssystem, was zum Teil automatisch, zum Teil auf Benutzer-Ratings beruht, das ist noch in der Mache.
Okay, ich will das mal zusammenfassen, was da jetzt, das glaube ich, noch nicht so ganz klar geworden ist. Also wann soll das stattfinden? Im Sommer? Sehe ich das richtig? Gibt es da schon Termine?
Am 9. September in Berlin.
Okay, am 9. September in Berlin, ich glaube am Bebelplatz, sollen dann so ein großer Tisch aufgebaut werden, so ein großer runder Tisch, wo 112 Leute dann Platz nehmen, die durch eine Jury, keine Ahnung, und so eine Gruppe ausgewählt werden. Und dann setzen die sich dahin und in vier Sessions, eine anderthalb Stunde, plappern die im Prinzip Antworten zu diesen 100 Fragen in die Kameras rein. Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, im Prinzip ist es so. Wir werden die 112 Personen nur für einen Tag zusammenholen können. Es wäre schön, die 112 Tage lang jeweils einen pro Tag befragen zu können. Das übersteigt aber die Möglichkeiten dieser doch sehr viel beschäftigten Leute. Wir werden die zu einem Tag zusammenholen und wir hoffen, dass das doch ein ziemlich magischer Moment wird, in dem diese 112 Personen dann jeweils vor einer eigenen Kamera, vor einem eigenen Mikrofon auf jede Frage in der Tat in vier Sitzungen über einen Tag verteilt ihre Antworten sprechen. Wir hoffen, dass die Antworten so interessant sind, so spannend sind, dass sie als Startguthaben für den globalen Dialog dienen können.
Da wird ja eine ganze Menge Material zusammenkommen. Wie viele Stunden sind das dann insgesamt?
Je nachdem, wie lange die Antworten ausfallen zwischen 500 und 700 Stunden.
Dann soll alles transkribiert werden und das Ganze fließt dann in eine Gesamtdatenbank der Antworten ein?
Richtig. Ob es wirklich auf dem August-Bebel-Platz sein wird oder auf einem anderen interessanten Platz in Berlin, steht nicht fest. Wir favorisieren im Moment den August-Bebel-Platz, weil er sehr schön zentral liegt und auch geschichtsträchtig ist. Diese 500 bis 700 Stunden müssen schon transkribiert werden, schon deshalb, um fortgeschrittene Suchtechnologie einsetzen zu können, um das ganze thematisch durchsuchbar zu machen. Sonst kann man überhaupt nicht nach Themen oder nach bestimmten Namen oder Begebenheiten oder Begriffen, Organisationen suchen. Wir werden darüber hinaus einen Teil der Texte sogar übersetzen müssen, denn wir können nicht erwarten, dass alle Teilnehmer aus aller Welt des Englischen so mächtig sind, dass sie all die Antworten flüssig auf Englisch geben können. Das ist ein gewaltiger Aufwand, der dort stattfinden muss, bevor die ganzen Inhalte dann wirklich auf dem Netz erscheinen.
Ich stelle mir natürlich auch vor, wenn jetzt 112 mehr oder weniger prominente Leute da rumlaufen, werden wir auch eine ganze Menge schwarze Hubschrauber am Himmel sehen. Das könnte auch noch mal ein kleines Sicherheitsproblem darstellen. Aber ist ja nach der Fußballweltmeisterschaft, da ist Berlin ja wahrscheinlich schon ausgebaut. Aber jetzt wollte ich noch mal kurz auf die Technik selber kommen, der Auswertung. Also mit welcher Software soll jetzt dieser gesamten Datenmenge zugesetzt werden?
Ja, wir werden für die Konversion und für das Streaming Standard-Software einsetzen. Wir werden Hilfe in Anspruch nehmen, zum Beispiel vom Internet Archive, wahrscheinlich von der BitTorrent-Bewegung, von wem auch immer wir die Hilfe bekommen können. Wir suchen noch nach weiteren Helfern und Sponsoren. Später die Suchsoftware, die ist, wie ich schon gesagt habe, zum Teil schon fertig. Die Forum-Software wird sich nicht so wesentlich von den besten Forum-Softwaren unterscheiden, die Threads verfolgen können und Benutzerkommentare erlauben, die es schon gibt. Was sich aber unterscheiden wird, ist nachher die Bewertung und auch die Visualisierung. Wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass wir bei der verwirrenden Anzahl von Themen, das sind ja tausende von Themen, die nachher auftauchen, die Verbindungen, die Querverbindungen auch so dargestellt werden, dass man das meiste aus den Antworten rauskriegt. Das heißt, wir wollen auch zum Beispiel Verbindungen zwischen sozialen Problemen aufzeigen, die ansonsten verborgen bleiben würden und das auch visuell deutlich machen. Das heißt, da werden wir eine Vernetzungssoftware nehmen und arbeiten im Moment daran.
Ist auch daran gedacht, die Daten so roh zu veröffentlichen und vielleicht die Auswertung auch durch Dritte zu ermöglichen?
Ja, das Schöne wird daran sein, dass jeder auf der Welt, der Zugang zum Internet hat, sich die Daten nicht nur in der aufbereiteten, kommentierten Form, sondern auch einfach roh als Audio- und Videodateien, wenn sie dann Audio- und Videodateien sind, oder später vielleicht auch eingegebene Texte, Kommentare, andere Antworten, andere Fragen runterladen kann und damit selber für die Bildung aus eigenem Interesse als Journalist vielleicht oder als Gesellschaftswissenschaftler, als Statistiker oder als Künstler damit seine eigenen Werke aufbauen kann. Alle diese Inhalte werden komplett frei verfügbar und kopierbar sein.
Ok, wir sind ja hier beim Chaosradio, da kann man auch mal ein bisschen technischer werden. Inwieweit werden da diese semantischen Modelle, was werden da für Techniken eingesetzt? Fällt das dann alles als RDF-Daten raus oder was ist das?
Ja, schön, dass Sie danach fragen. Die meisten Leute fragen immer nur danach, ob man sich das auch runterladen kann. Es wird so sein, dass zusätzlich zu den rohen Text-Dateien, wir natürlich die Dateien mit Metadaten versehen werden. Wir haben dazu eine sehr komplexe Ontologie für soziale Thematik aufgebaut, die wir aber in großen Teilen von der Union der internationalen Assoziationen, das ist so eine Art Verband oder Datenbank, der Non-Governmental Organizations von rund 40.000 Organisationen rund um die Welt aufgebaut hat. Wir werden diese Daten als Metadaten im RDF-Format speichern und wiedergeben. Das heißt, es wird darunter natürlich auch die üblichen Kernmetadaten im Dublin Core geben, aber wir wollen schon darüber weiter hinausgehen, weil einfach die Materie so komplex ist. Die Thematik ist eine mehrdimensionale, das heißt nach mehreren Attributen hierarchisch organisierte Ontologie braucht.
Klingt nach einem lustigen Sandkasten für Wissenschaftler und solche, die es werden wollen. Wenn jetzt Leute Lust haben, sich da technisch mit einzubringen oder vielleicht auch gute Vorschläge haben, wie man jetzt diese drohende Datenflut dort noch weiter auswerten kann, wo kann man sich dann hinwenden?
Ja, das ist so, das kommt genau zur richtigen Zeit, diese Frage. Wir haben uns gerade in den letzten Tagen, weil wir sehr, sehr gute Kommentare bekommen haben, muss ich sagen, unter anderem von dem Interview, dieses Interviews selbst, haben wir uns dazu entschlossen, unsere Webseite auch dahingehend zu erweitern, also die Webseite von Dropping Knowledge, dass wir neben der Fragensammlung, die wir schon machen, und da fordern wir jeden auf, auch Fragen beizusteuern, auch Ideen sammeln werden. Das heißt also, wenn wir von aus dem Bereich der Besucher unserer Webseite Kommentare kriegen könnten oder Anregungen und Ideen, wie wir diese Idee noch ausbauen wollen, denn in der Community, da liegt die Power, dann würden wir uns sehr freuen, wenn diese Kommentare auch in großer Zahl eingegeben werden.
Ich glaube, das Projekt könnte noch ein Wiki und ein Webblog gebrauchen, meiner Meinung nach. Ein Wiki und ein Webblog könnte das Projekt noch gebrauchen.
Das Webblog ist bereits in der Mache. Ob wir ein eigenes Wiki einstellen, wissen wir nicht, aber wir fangen erst mal an, dass wir ein Webblog erlauben und die Möglichkeit geben, eigene Ideen zu geben, vielleicht sogar mit Threading. Wenn es sich dann als gut erweisen sollte, dass wir noch ein Wiki dazu bauen, tun wir es auch.
Teil dieses Projektes ist jetzt die Produktion von verschiedenen Filmen. Neben einigen Eigenwerbe-Filmen ist unter anderem vorgestern ein Film released worden, der ein bisschen Abfallprodukt war, von dem, was eigentlich geplant war. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ursprünglich geht es ja darum, da auch einen Film zu machen, der Themen der Globalisierung, Global Warming in den Mittelpunkt stellt. Dabei ist dann eine spezielle Dokumentation nochmal abgefallen über New Orleans und die Situation dort. 5, 6 Monate nachdem der Hurricane Katrina dort diese Überschwemmung ausgelöst hat. Der Film ist vor ein paar Tagen ins Internet gestellt worden. Angekündigt war eine Copy-Left-Lizenz. In dem Film selber war dann wiederum eine Creative Commons-Lizenz angegeben, die die kommerzielle Verwendung nicht ermöglicht. Was ist jetzt da der Hintergrund der Konfusion? Weil da gab es ja einige Diskussionen auch in der Blogosphäre drum.
Richtig. Da ist uns, naja, wie im wirklichen Leben, was passiert, was wir nicht vorher gesehen haben, das Interesse an einer wirklichen Copy-Left-Verbreitung im Copy-Left-Sinne, das heißt also eine völlig uneingeschränkte Verbreitung, ließ sich dann doch letzten Endes nicht sofort ermöglichen, weil noch einige Rechte an Musikstücken geklärt werden mussten. Und naja, bei dieser Klärung der Rechte geht es dann, das waren ältere Musikstücke, die unter anderem vielleicht auch im Besitz von sehr guten Musikern sind, mit denen man sich es nicht verderben will, geht also weniger darum, ob wir jetzt bestimmte Paragrafen beachten oder nicht. Wir sind im Moment dabei, das zu klären und werden in kurzer Zeit das soweit haben, dass wir entweder auf diese Musik verzichten oder aber hoffentlich die Rechte alle kriegen, sodass wir es dann völlig Copy-Left machen können. Das ist schon das Ziel.
Ja gut, ich denke auch, die Fixierung auf Copy-Left, ich weiß nicht inwieweit sie jetzt wirklich wichtig ist für den Film. Gut finde ich auf jeden Fall schon mal, dass er halt unter Creative-Commons-Lizenz generell verfügbar ist und dadurch halt auch frei kopierbar ist. Auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Stück Dokumentarfilm an der Stelle. Ja, bedanke ich mich recht herzlich für das Interview und dann machen wir wieder weiter mit was anderem. Ja, soweit das erste Interview mit dem Hans-Oskar-Ad, dieser Film, der jetzt gegen Ende des Interviews angesprochen wurde, ist dann der zweite Grund, warum ich das Ganze hier für den Podcast interessant fand. Es geht halt um New Orleans und es ist eigentlich auch kein besonders großartiger Epos, der dabei rausgekommen ist, aber er zeigt einfach sehr schön, wie die Situation dort vor Ort ist und ich finde es einfach gut, dass solche Filme auch unter freien Lizenzen verfügbar gemacht werden. Und da ich jetzt auch selber seinerzeit diese Situation in New Orleans, als es also dort drunter und drüber ging, die ganze Katastrophe, das sichtbar wurde, das selber ein bisschen verfolgt habe und auch auf meine Art und Weise mit dieser Common Ground Initiative, die gleich in dem Interview noch mal zur Sprache kommt, meine Berührung hatte, hat mich das eben besonders interessiert und ich habe mich jetzt halt noch mal mit dem Regisseur des Films, dem Ralf Schmerberg, noch mal darüber unterhalten, wie das so war und welche Erfahrungen er dort vor Ort gesammelt hat, die man jetzt vielleicht so aus dem Film selber nicht rauslesen kann. Der Film selber ist einerseits auf der Dropping-Knowledge-Webseite, droppingknowledge.org, verfügbar. Ich hatte ihn allerdings vor ein paar Tagen auch schon hier in den Chaosradio Podcast geworfen. Die Leute von euch, die das also abonniert haben, haben den wahrscheinlich schon. Okay, dann spielen wir mal das zweite Interview ab. Ralf Schmerberg, du bist Filmregisseur hauptberuflich, du bist auch hier mit dabei bei dieser Dropping-Knowledge-Initiative und du hast jetzt hier im Rahmen der Präsentation auch einen neuen Film vorgestellt, der von New Orleans gehandelt hat. Kannst du vielleicht mal kurz was zur Genese und Entstehungsgeschichte dieses Films erzählen, wie dieser Film entstanden ist?
Ja, also erstmal war er nicht geplant und ist aus dem Momentum des Erlebens raus entstanden, was ich eigentlich sehr spannend fand. Im Prinzip waren wir für Dropping Knowledge eigentlich auf einer Weltreise, um so eine Stimmung zu Global Warming, Climate Change, Ressourcen und Unachtsamkeit von Leuten irgendwie so überall in der Welt zu filmen. Dazu waren wir halt in Bombay, Peking, Caracas, Mexico City und sind dann in New Orleans gelandet und wollten eigentlich in New Orleans nur mit ein paar Leuten Interviews machen, die so vom Climate Change getroffen wurden. Und als wir dann ankamen und den vollen Scope erfasst haben, mir war nicht bewusst, das was wir dann erlebt haben und gesehen haben. Mich hat das wirklich an dem Tag direkt getroffen. Und zum einen war da diese Stimmung erst mal, als wir raus sind, dass man sich in so eine Apokalypse bewegt. Also erst mal wussten wir gar nicht die Hintergründe, wir waren einfach in der Gegend. Und ich dachte so irgendwie, ich bin in einem Atomschlag, so der letzte Mensch irgendwie oder so. Ich bin da rumgelaufen mit der Kamera und da war niemand und das war auch beängstigend. Und dann haben wir uns mehr mit den Umständen auseinandergesetzt und sind auf diese Common Ground Leute gestoßen, die einfach in diesem Niemandsland da sind und dieses Stück Land verteidigen, diesen Lower Ninth Ward. Und ganz aus dem Moment heraus ist dann dieser Film entstanden. Es sind auch auf der Reise andere Filme entstanden, interessanterweise. Aber als wir zurück kamen, haben wir den dann als erstes geschnitten, weil er mich doch am schwersten irgendwie aus den Schuhen gekippt hat.
Lower Ninth Ward, das ist, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, der am härtesten betroffene Bezirk, da wo auch die Dämme als erstes gebrochen sind, richtig?
Naja, das ist eine Gegend, wo man vor 100 Jahren oder so den Schwarzen ein Stück Land gegeben hat, nachdem die Sklaverei aufgehört hat. Das sind also ganz alte, traditionelle Familien und denen hat man natürlich das schlechteste Stück Land gegeben von New Orleans und das liegt halt unter dem Meerwisspiegel. Zum Rum geht dieser Damm. Und das ist sowieso, sagen wir mal, eine unsichere Gegend. Einmal durch die Situation mit dem Damm und dass es halt drunter liegt. Und gleichzeitig ist es auch eine Gegend, die schon lange irgendwie die Industrie, es ist schwer interessiert dort einfach industrielle Ansiedlungen zu machen. Und die nützen das halt jetzt komplett aus, dass sie die Leute los geworden sind durch den Katrina und lassen die einfach nicht mehr auf ihr persönliches Eigentum zurück. Die halten die einfach raus.
Das heißt, die dürfen auch gar nicht rein in das Gebiet?
Das kann ich nicht so bestimmt sagen. Das wird ihnen auf jeden Fall mega schwer gemacht. Und es ist das einzige Gegend, wo der Strom nicht wieder angeknipst wurde, das Wasser nicht angeknipst ist, wo keine Aufräumteams rein sind. Die Leute dort bekommen keine Notbehausung. Der Rest von New Orleans, der weiß es, da steht vor jedem zerstörten Haus ein Wohnwagentrailer, ein sehr großzügiger Wohnwagentrailer, um den Leuten Shelter zu geben. Aber dieser Gegend verweigert man halt eigentlich jede Hilfe. Man hat einfach dieses Gelände komplett so gelassen, wie Zeit im Wirbelstrom.
Das sieht man ja auch in den Aufnahmen, in dem Film. Ich glaube, das ist alles so, als wäre es zwei Tage nach dem Hurricane gefilmt worden. Aber das war jetzt wie lange nach dem Einschlag?
Naja, wir waren praktisch am 155. Tag danach da, also fast sechs Monate.
Unglaublich. Es ist ja nicht so, dass nichts getan wird, aber die Arbeit, die dort geleistet wird, beschränkt sich offensichtlich nur auf einige Gebiete.
Ja, also was hier einfach passiert ist, vom Eindruck her, wie wir das wahrgenommen haben, einfach eine sehr Corporation-gestörte oder Macht-gestörte Vertreibung. Ich glaube, dieser weisen Gesellschaft ist es einfach recht, dass hier die Leute los sind. Das ist einfach eine ganz miese Form von sich eines Problems entledigen. Ich meine, New Orleans hat ja eigentlich eine schwarze Seele. So sieht es die Welt und schwarze Kultur. Und es ist one of the most blackest population gewesen. Und durch diesen Wirbelsturm hat sich das komplett verändert. Ich meine, es sind ja, ich glaube, von 850.000 Einwohnern 150.000 zurückgekehrt. Und das sind halt schon viele Weise.
Und die anderen 700.000 verteilen sich jetzt sozusagen in den umliegenden Gebieten in Louisiana und in Texas?
Ja, ich glaube, die sind über ganz Amerika bis nach Kanada hoch verteilt. Und die, die näher sind, die versuchen zurückzukommen. Aber das sind ja alles arme Leute, die haben überhaupt keine Möglichkeiten, auch sich selbst jetzt wieder aufzubauen. Im Prinzip sind das soziale Flüchtlinge jetzt. Und man hat die halt schön verteilt. Dadurch haben die natürlich auch keine Stimme. Die sind irgendwie halt auf sich selbst zurückgestellt. Das sind alte Leute, das sind schwache Familien, das sind sozial schwierig gestellte Familien. Und mit denen kann man natürlich vielleicht dieses Spiel auch treiben. Und die haben auch keine Lobby, die sich wirklich um ihre Rechte einsetzt oder so.
Hattet ihr Schwierigkeiten dort zu filmen? Seid ihr da in irgendeiner Form auf Probleme gestoßen, da euch frei zu bewegen in dem Gebiet?
Nee, wir hatten keine Probleme. Es gab zwei, drei Hubschrauben über dem Gelände, aber es gab in dem Gelände eigentlich auch so einen Common Ground Leute. Also wir haben in diesem Gelände im Prinzip sechs Menschen angetroffen. Und das waren zwei alte, schwarze Frauen, die zurückgekehrt sind, um sich das Haus, ihre Kinder anzugucken. Die heulen davor, standen und völlig fassungslos. Und das war für uns natürlich wahnsinnig dann doch ergreifend, weil du warst ja hier in der Gaststadt, und dann haben wir halt diese vier Leute von Common Ground getroffen und das war's mehr oder weniger.
Common Ground ist so eine Privatinitiative von Leuten, die sich bereit erklärt haben, dort zu helfen. Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, was die eigentlich machen, die besetzen sogar das Land damit, es nicht niedergeweißt wird von Planierraupen. Und versuchen halt dort eine Struktur wieder anzusiedeln, dass die ersten Leute zurückkommen können. Das Problem ist einfach, wenn nicht da die ersten Leute anfangen, wieder zu wohnen, dann ist es natürlich noch viel leichter, letztendlich dieses Stück Land dann sich wirklich einzufallern. Eigentlich sind das Landverteidiger, und gleichzeitig machen sie eine Sozialarbeit, beraten die Leute, die ihr Haus verloren haben, versuchen wenn welche zurückzukommen, Notdürftige, Shelters zu bauen, ja, solche Geschichten.
Und so, wie sich dir das dargestellt hat, gibt es überhaupt noch irgendeinen Ausblick, wie das weitergehen soll in New Orleans? Das klingt ja jetzt so, als müsste es da demnächst Aufstände geben oder fehlt da den Leuten die Kraft? Das fehlt wahrscheinlich vor allem an Leuten.
Aufstände kann es nicht geben, weil es keine Leute mehr gibt. Aber was passiert ist halt ein extrem hohes Maß an Ungerechtigkeit und dadurch entsteht Frustration. Und das wird sich irgendwann in einer späteren Generation oder in ein paar Jahren auf nicht klar darstellbare Weise bestimmt wieder auswirken. Ich meine, wo Ungerechtigkeit entsteht, entstehen wütende Leute und irgendwann drehen da paar durch. Ob da jetzt einer mit der Shotgun rumläuft, weil seine Gefühle gestört sind. Oder, ich meine, da gibt es genug Möglichkeiten für die Fantasie. Ich meine, was den Leuten da wieder führt, ist auf jeden Fall eine große Form von Demütigung. Und Demütigung in der Regel entlädt sich oft irgendwann noch mal in was anderem Negativen.
Wie war denn dein Gefühl, als ihr dann davon wieder abgereistet? Wie lange wart ihr eigentlich da? Wie lange habt ihr da gedreht?
Einen Tag von 9 Uhr bis um 5, als die Sonne weg war.
Also der ganze Film ist an einem Tag entstanden quasi.
Jaja, das ist für mich sowieso überraschend.
Und was ist so dein, ja, weiß man gar nicht, was man da zu fragen soll.
Was mein nächstes Projekt ist.
Nein, ich meine, was die, wenn man sich da so aufhält, ich mein, ein Tag ist natürlich nicht sehr viel, aber was für ein Gefühl nimmt man daraus mit?
Naja, man muss sagen, das hört sich jetzt oberflächlich an, wenn wir einen Tag da waren. Das Interessante war ja im Prinzip, dass wir, ich weiß nicht, fünf Tage vorher noch in Bombay saßen. Da waren wir in Slums und Müllverbrennungsanlagen, haben uns auch ein anderes, ein mieses Loch der Welt angeguckt, wo man versucht normalerweise nicht hinzugehen oder so. Dann waren wir in Caracas, haben uns mit Chavez auseinandergesetzt, wieder das World Social Forum instrumentalisiert für seine revolutionäre Diktatorship. Bevor wir nach New Orleans gekommen sind, haben wir schon fünf, sechs richtig andere, harten Geschichten gesehen. Prinzipiell sind wir mal rein ins Flugzeug, runter, für mich jetzt von der Empfindung eine harte Geschichte rein, wieder raus. New York hat dann alles getoppt, weil das auch sehr surreal war. New Orleans natürlich, weil es sehr surreal war. Wir sind dann raus, zum einen mit dem Wunsch zu bleiben, weil diese Leute, die dort sind, diese Common Ground, die hatten für mich was unglaublich Kräftiges und Einmaliges. Die waren wirklich so wie, in der Apokalypse triffst du noch einen Menschen und bei dem willst du dann bleiben. Das heißt, ich hatte mich auf eine verrückte Weise bei denen wohlgefühlt, weil sie einfach so eine Standhaftigkeit hatten. Und ich bin natürlich auch weggegangen, einfach mit einer unglaublichen, das kann doch alles nicht wahr sein. Und es ist natürlich klar, wenn du Medien siehst, das ist ja halt ja immer noch eine Distanz, selbst wenn du da mitten drin stehst, dann wird dir das so, so, so, so sehr bewusst. Ich meine, ich bin ja in die Häuser der Leute rein und hab einfach wahnsinnig... Ich musste immer mit einer inneren Traurigkeit kämpfen und der eigenen Standhaftigkeit das jetzt zu machen. Also ich hatte auch das Gefühl, ich bin in einem Friedhof und alle Särge sind offen oder so. Es war, so war das, ja.
Was entsteht jetzt noch aus dem Dropping Knowledge-Projekt heraus an weiteren Filmen, aus dem restlichen Material?
Also wir wissen das alles nicht, weil wir ja nicht zielgesetzt arbeiten. Aus der Reise jetzt, wo wir zurückkommen, werden wir bestimmt in den nächsten zwei Wochen noch zwei, drei andere Filme in so einer Länge, weil wir sind ja von der Länge unabhängig. Das heißt, wenn eine Geschichte fünf Minuten hergibt, machen wir fünf raus, wenn es 20 sind, 20. Das heißt, wir werden jetzt erst mal diese Reise weiterschneiden. Es gibt bestimmt noch einen Film hier aus den Slums in Dwali. Es gibt bestimmt mal einen Film hier mit Chavez, weil das fand ich unglaublich, unglaublich. Und dann muss man so sehen. Und wenn wir dann mit allem fertig sind, und es auf die Website gesetzt haben, dann sind wir eigentlich gerade dabei, schon die nächste Reise zu planen und einfach weiterzumachen und so Splitter aus der Welt zurückzubringen. Zum anderen beobachten wir natürlich ganz aufmerksam, was in der Welt passiert und in den Medien und fangen uns eigentlich jetzt an, so darauf vorzubereiten, irgendwie so, wenn etwas ist, wo wir das Gefühl haben, da wollen wir hin und wollen ein zusätzliches Bild zu den, was sagen wir mal, die klassischen Medien liefern, einfach ein zusätzliches Bild schaffen oder unsere persönliche Meinung von etwas auch. Also hingehen, anschauen, was du siehst, wiedergeben, so aller Zeitzeuge oder so. Dann stellen wir uns eigentlich so vor, wenn irgendwas passiert, wo wir meinen, dass wir das kommentieren wollen, dass wir innerhalb von einem Tag in der Lage sein müssen, dort zu sein und sofort mit Kameras das zu drehen und dann sofort wieder zurück und das zu schneiden und dann sofort aufs Web. Also die Idee ist ja hier, von dieser Arbeitsweise her ist ja nicht alles, was Dropping Knowledge macht. Wir reden jetzt nur mal über die Copy-Left-Filme. Eigentlich diese Situation rauszukommen, wo ein Filmemacher oder ein Künstler, wenn ihnen etwas stört oder wenn ihnen etwas empfindet, dass es nicht sein kann, dass es drei oder vier Jahre dauert, bis ich eine Finanzierung habe, bis ich einen Film zusammenhabe, bis ich einen Verleih habe, bis ich ein Festival mich akzeptiere. Also um diesen ganzen Weg, wo es dann eigentlich keinen mehr interessiert, weil es dann immer so retrospektiv ist, ja damals hatten wir das Problem, jetzt gucken wir uns den Film dazu an, sondern wirklich zu versuchen, das radikal zu verkürzen, dass man wirklich in der Lage ist, unter Umständen nach 10 Tagen bis 2 Wochen, das finde ich momentan so in reales Zeitfenster, wirklich zu reagieren. Und dieses Immediately-Reaction, ich habe das jetzt gemerkt mit dem Katrina-Film für mich, und vor allem, dass ich auch einfach mit niemand reden musste, ob ich diesen Film mache, ob er diesen Film will, ob es diesen Film braucht, ob er mir den bezahlt, ob ich einen Verleiher habe, ob ich akzeptiert und nicht werde damit. Also diese ganze Geschichte, die ein Regisseur ja durchmacht, die ich völlig überflüssig und anstrengend finde mittlerweile nach der Erfahrung, da wollen wir so hin. Und die Idee ist ja eigentlich, Dropping Knowledge auch, sagen wir mal jetzt von der Plattform Gedanken her natürlich, okay, jetzt mal diese Möglichkeit kennen zu lernen, davon zu berichten, andere zu inspirieren und dann auf diese Plattform oder auch auf andere Plattformen, die entstehen, weil wir überhaupt keinen Anspruch von Uniqueness haben hier. Vielleicht eine neue zusätzliche Form von Mitmuschung. Ja, mitmischen, mitsprechen, einmischen, eine Stimme haben. Ich finde es einfach nicht mehr für mich zeitgemäß auf eine Demo zu gehen und dann gehe ich wieder nach Hause, sondern ich wollte einfach, und da haben wir auch Dropping Knowledge mitgegründet, irgendwie eine Möglichkeit finden, da stärker und direkter irgendwie dagegen anzugehen, was mir jetzt persönlich nicht passt. Das ist ja für jeden subjektiv. Da kann ja jeder für sich selber sehen. Es will ja nie jemand sagen, was das ist jetzt.
Ja, okay, ich bedanke mich für das schöne Interview. Und ich denke, wir werden demnächst bei droppingknowledge.org noch weitere Filme und weitere Projekte sehen. Okay, soweit die beiden Interviews zu diesem Projekt. Ich denke, es sollte klar geworden sein, warum ich das jetzt hier mit eingebracht habe. Und ich bin gespannt, was bei dem ganzen Projekt herauskommt. Da scheinen auch noch einige Fragen offen zu sein. Nicht nur die, die dann später beantwortet werden sollen. Ja, dieser Podcast ist jetzt deutlich kürzer geworden als die letzten. Deswegen haben wir jetzt hier auch noch ein bisschen Zeit, die ich ausnahmsweise mal mit dem Spielen von Musik nutzen werde. Die Musik, die ihr bisher gehört habt und auch das, was jetzt gleich noch lauter kommt, kommt alles von der Website ccmixta.org, die sich dem Remakes von Creative Commons Musik verschrieben hat. Und ich kann euch nur empfehlen, euch da auch mal umzuschauen. Da kann man sich das auch alles als Podcast abonnieren. Ich an dieser Stelle sag jetzt erstmal Tschüss. Am Mikrofon war Tim Pritlove, bis bald.